buenos días lo primero es que el
gobierno acaba de confirmar que los
residentes de los ancianatos y sus
cuidadores serán los primeros en recibir
esta vacuna se espera que se inicie la
próxima semana el gobierno su objetivo
inicial es que la mayoría de la
población esté vacunada para la
primavera de 2021 es decir para mitad de
marzo del próximo año ha comprado por
ello 40 millones de dosis de esta vacuna
de facer que servirán para inmunizar 20
millones de personas cada persona
requiere dos dosis espaciadas por 20
días de diferencia aquí la gran pregunta
y lo complejo será la logística de todo
este proceso el reino unido- tiene 64
millones de personas y se ha hablado de
que ya están listos 50 hospitales en
todo el país ya están listos
completamente para recibir la vacuna
también habrá centros especiales para
trabajar las 24 horas del día
prácticamente los 7 días de la semana
para lograr esta meta para la primavera
y también las farmacias y los médicos de
los barrios
la vacuna también otro de los retos de
la logística será el almacenamiento y
transporte de esta vacuna porque
requiere un sistema de menos 70 grados
para que pueda utilizarse de ahí también
la complejidad para el transporte aquí
al reino unido se espera que además del
personal de la salud la administre
también estudiantes de medicina es
hablado incluso de que personal del
ejército también prestará esta labor